and we are live
welcome
to the last word lord cognito anybody's
fresh on that friday night campfire or
thursday night what am i talking about
thursday evening campfire with thai guy
travis and the crew let's start with e
how are we doing sir doing good i've
officially crossed the hundred hour mark
in eldon ring
damn wow yep
level one four
two
i'm getting up there so i beat
not in game level i almost beat the fire
giant last night which is a whole thing
and i know that's kind of like an event
towards
i'm getting to the end part we're
getting there so
uh enjoying that one
and i will definitely say currently
shopping for a mattress
and you okay so you're like all right
there's purple there's tempurpedic and
you go online and you search and you've
heard of casper and then there's you
know lisa and i've like heard of
different ones through podcast
advertisements and then i was like okay
i've heard of these you go to websites
and top mattresses for like 2022 and
then i put out a tweet
i was like hey i've heard of these
mattresses does anybody have any
recommendations i think i had like seven
brands in there
now that i'm done with the tweet i think
i have 14 brands to pick from
it is
and honestly they all seem to be about
the same if you get the hybrid with some
coils about seven different layers of
memory foam a cooling thing they all end
up being about the same so i just gotta
eventually decide on one but ours is
just finally getting to the point where
i'm like you know it's probably time so
looking into the world of mattresses but
uh yeah i did the final raid challenge
this week so done all right i don't
think i've ever done the raid challenges
in destiny 2. much of them
so that's completely my bad
uh shout out to gaming forte welcome to
the last word podcast episode number 193
i'm ready for another great conversation
on the campfire so let's get right into
it love you guys same to you forte
uh but yeah just you know playing
destiny playing elden ring and
doing a little spring cleaning and
apparently uh you know home shopping
stuff which is just hurts your head
sometimes what about you travis what are
you doing
i uh have been absolutely buried in ign
work um
i've got a review going live on monday
that we've been working on this week i
got a preview going live next week at
some point uh that i've been working on
uh a raid guide that i'm trying to
finish with destin but he's super busy
so he's in a time uh yeah just man just
buried in projects and basically
haven't
last week i played a lot of games and
this week i've just been writing about
games i haven't really played games
at all this week a little bit of destiny
i'm gonna do my uh my iron banner this
week but uh yeah it's just been a super
busy week i'm here alone at my house uh
all week so i've just i've just made it
like the ultimate productivity week for
me just like smashing through like 18
hours of work every day so it's been
it's been cool but uh we're excited to
talk about destiny
man
yeah man um
same thing as travis it's been an insane
two weeks this week not as bad as last
week but cause last week was crazy
clearly i missed
but um yeah man this week uh just been
kind of catching up doing shows has a
great ddu with uh travis okay that came
through talking about you know
freelancing in journalism
fantastic perspective shout out to ty
shout out to maddie really cool show i
advise people to check that out and then
as far as on the gaming side uh
definitely one i got a so shout out to
the crew shout out to forte and the crew
and um sinister everybody dj we got some
raids done i got my divinity finally
hey-hey
putting it off for so long that i like
because you could be like i'm gonna go
get divinity and guess what it's done
it's not like i could run three vlogs
for 12 weeks in a row and not get it so
i approve of the divinity
nice yeah so we did divinity we did it
was kind of like a little raid special
we did that we went tried to do lazarus
to not get me 1k for the 1 millionth
time i'm getting into travis territory
1k it's just to the point where it's
just like i'm just running it because
they want me to run it and i know i'm
not good either but i'm so far behind
attempts on you so yeah yeah that one's
a hard one to to not have to because
that rate is so damn long
thankfully you know they get the
checkpoints to try to get it get me
through that we rocked that out i got a
run on uh what's called this week i
haven't run it yet but i did start my i
stuck in some banner a lot of banner
last night so i got a lot to talk about
that and um yeah man that's been pretty
much it what about you and we this uh
amazing guest that's been very patient
indeed so shout out real quick to
necromancer zale cog show me your
warlock build you're gonna have to tweet
this out apparently it's really the lock
belts right here
you don't see that that's my one second
storm collar
you don't see that boy 3.0 oh my god
you look like a titan [ __ ] yeah i'm very
excited you know we strong warlocks over
here
it was like the male titan still does
not look like that
or the male the male warlock does not
look like
they look like this
shoulders that are like robes the male
titan has shoulders like out to here and
then you could put like a little warlock
up on your shoulder
look man warlocks lift bro
[ __ ] how you gonna fit a bond around
those biceps come on there's no way
you're just gonna be able to do that
anyway
we're gonna need a cut we're gonna need
a custom fit bond work here for a
calculator please yeah
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave the joke out
about custom bondage but i'll let you
guys take that
welcome to the last word episode number
193
the disciple has thrown all the
challenges it has lego may have just
released the ultimate skywalker
experience and no man's sky is the game
that continues to surprise us all the
world of video games continue to keep us
entertained and our guest was lucky
enough to have a mom who helped him pick
up this first controller many years ago
starting out gaming on the snes is like
having your first movie be award-worthy
you can't help but get hooked like many
of us did
a man with true respect for the epic
game epic platformer games which shows
us he enjoys both a tough challenge and
immense satisfaction that those bring
out in all of us the desire to face
something difficult and tackle it
head-on is really the only thing way
this man knows to be
two teammates and a grandmaster go down
that's fine he's going to take a deep
breath and finish festering course solo
for that grand master clutch up in 20
minutes by himself why stop there he
just steps into a grand master ring on
his own and makes easy work of these
nightmares nightfalls that many of us
fear to go in with a group so let's
welcome a member of clan masanko
distinguished consumer of advanced ug
like many of us in game soloist and also
clutch teammate and honestly one of the
nicest most humble guys in gaming the
one the only zombie the bloody
i mean save the blade welcome it's our
pleasure to have you join us how you
doing sabe
i'm doing all right just you know just
chilling just got done uh helping
another gamer uh get his conqueror today
oh nice um
yeah he if he was a 50 year old guy he
was he was an awesome dude that's my
generation you gotta you gotta go slow
with us you're not 50 yet you don't have
to round that
hey zero revise i got you
that's what's up
man good to have you man it's really
cool seeing the content stuff like that
so we got we got to talk about this this
gaming prior i see some very unique
titles and stuff like that so just from
the beginning like briefly you know
some of the things that really just got
you into gaming in general i don't know
like for me it's just like i said i was
like uh as a child like like my mother
was a gamer like oh okay she always
played like mrs pacman and stuff like
that and i remember on like christmas
day i was like five it was like 1984.
like she got me at s
nes and
you know i got me the all-stars and you
know i and i like one of the first games
i played with super mario brothers 3. i
still love that game that's still epic
i just love platformers and then you
know as i got like older
oh you know i've been more into like the
fps and all that other stuff
i mean with a little splash of like uh
racing games something like a knee for
speed or something okay
do you play like need for speed
underground hot pursuit what are we
talking about underground too
okay that's favorite speed that's the
one
so for platformers just wanted to kind
of go into that a little more and know
you played like mario 3 super mario
world the epic ones
any modern platformers that have like
pulled you in or sucked you in because
there's some very good ones these days
as well
uh
i will be lying if i said i didn't um
play any other platformers
oh you haven't played me in a while
well like in a while like it's just been
well destiny
hey
nothing wrong with that sometimes
it gets its hooks into all of us at some
point a little more than others
nice nice nice trav you want to jump in
yeah so you said that you have been
kind of been on the fps chain for a
while or less fps oh yeah like you know
like uh like one of the first like my my
first one like it was probably like uh
uh the original call of duty modern
warfare like you know cool
yeah and like call of duty 4. but i
wasn't like competitive anything it was
just like you know it was just like a
game i like playing
and then
um you know
obviously uh
mw2 came that was cool and stuff like
that but then like one of my favorite
series in the call of duty franchises
the blackout series because you know um
especially black ops 2 all-time favorite
game of mines um classic classic um
you know i see we're just running there
with a bacon remington
running people over you know
[Music]
oh yeah yeah i feel like that picked him
was like some of the best that they have
in the game at least
yeah that changed the game it it it made
it different from it felt like a
different experience from the modern
warfare series they added their own spin
to it so i feel you on that oh yeah all
right you know
that was like one of those games i was
just like so hooked into until destiny
well speaking of destiny you got to give
us the story how did you get into it
what was the first time you played were
you one of the
alpha or how long you've been playing
let's hear the story
okay yep i i got you um because i
remember like it was like day one um
so i actually was not playing the game
for destiny i literally
bought uh i just got off a
quitting uh yugioh i used to play i used
to play that like for many years i used
to play competitively um
all my cards and i bought this ps4
with destiny as a special edition i was
like oh and and i think call of duty
advanced warfare was coming out that
year and
i'm just like oh i could just play this
game until uh
jesse you know come out i mean i mean so
uh
vince warfare and i'm out of here
it was a placeholder for you
it was a placeholder yes it was
until advanced
but rating
i'll tell you
rating was a thing that uh got me
playing in this game but at a time i did
but um but not to like go too short
about it but yeah i literally got it um
oh my
literally got it you know just uh um
my main is hunter so i like i picked
under the person
i was like
he said oh a cape
i cannot
i was like oh i could become a cake
champion i was like i ain't going to be
no big old titan or no
worry about that i mean you could have
wear warlocks but you don't look you
want to be sleek you want to get your
cape on you want to be stealthy you know
i got you
i know i mean
but now but nowadays i'm playing like
all three of them and
i just love playing them so
um
but yeah uh i think like uh when i did
uh try to uh you know go back to the
series um
i wasn't a fan of where where the game
went and i fully just went on destiny
because uh
it was because like you know the story
you know overall gamepl
you know you're going around in crucible
shooting your weapons and all these
little abilities and stuff that's what
it originally drew me personally um good
point
um
but rating was um a thing that i still
continue to do and i love to do just
simply because like um especially
nowadays i like i i go and like uh
go on my way to like you know make sure
a lot of my friends and community
members you know get their stuff done
because uh i could tell you
uh i didn't know where the sherpa was
for the first time and i i met one and
you know d1 but he was like he was like
he was like one of those toxic sherpas
oh
stay on the plate why are you waiting
he posted like a shirt because i used to
use lmg a lot
because because i really have like no
friends to play the game and stuff like
that so
usually uh solo so um
i remember um getting kicked out of that
group
yep and i found out what a sherpa was
and that person wasn't a sherpa yeah so
that's really i used to spend like my
endless times going to like patrols and
doing bounties and
spin metal farming
yes yep pretty much
a lot of people don't know that you
needed materials to level things up oh
yeah oh yeah yeah so like
i remember i remember that faithful day
like you know like um
some
um a random person like you know i
started on playstation four so uh
uh i got the invite to
um to um i accepted it because you know
i ain't have any friends and i could
already done like the story i was level
20
uh and back in the day you couldn't get
to level 30 unless you played ball of
glass hard mm-hmm
and
and i think that was like the only place
you get the helmet but um
but uh i remember uh going with this
person this person was very grateful and
then he he introduced me to another
there's this he he introduced me to
another sherpa and
i at the at this time i was just like i
don't want to go through that again
because like my experience
yeah uh that experience almost made me
quit destiny
um
so
uh after that um i mean
i told him experience i want to do it uh
[Music]
um it was a guy named tro57 i remember
his name dearly because he was the
person that taught me everything in d1
so dope shout out to trump seven
yeah yeah um you know he he literally
carried me through a ball of glass for
my first time
and i saw what rating was and
and i wanted to be you know you know
like
he took me under his wing and taught me
everything about the game and
now now i've you know i just help people
you know so mm-hmm
i just want to stop you for a second
because i think it's a powerful story
i'll give it to you because i know you
had a question but um i think it's
important to say that because we we
share very similar experiences that as
far as i'm
not almost willing to quit destiny until
the raid right and then learning about
the raid and then getting that
experience so
obviously you had a negative experience
at first with a sherpa but then you
ended up having a positive one with
someone that kind of took you under
under the wing so my question is once
you now are in this raid right and
you're experiencing it and like for the
first time like what was it i know what
it is for me what rating means to me but
i wanted to know what was the excitement
was it just the puzzles the encounters
was it the drops like what was it about
rating that made you fall in love with
that aspect of destiny
oh oh yeah that's pretty much it like
you know like i cuz i know there's like
raids in like other games you know
and stuff like that um
but you know i never been i guess like
being with a group of people trying to
do puzzles and
uh finding finding like a mechanic to
beat beat on a big old boss
and
and getting like cool loot was what got
me into rating and
i remember um
doing reset every week doing three raids
every week
and doing even more
um if i need to so
but yeah
nice nice
you got a question yeah well as we're
talking about raids and that definitely
is one of the big pieces of your kind of
experience and definitely one of the
things you enjoy doing outside of some
other in-game stuff obviously we'll get
to here in a little bit but
as for raids have you so you've been
playing since d1 is there any raid you
haven't done in the destiny franchise or
have you done them all
oh i did them all okay so now the
question
is we gotta know your favorite three
raids number one number two and number
three
oh he's starting trouble early
gotta do it
if this is like hey has raids hooked me
i got in here all right well so we gotta
go
we gotta go top three raids top three
oh
okay my top three raises uh you know
about um i'll disciple uh i absolutely
do love uh
the fact that uh we're not just sitting
in a well in bubble and just uh
just killing them boss because i feel
like most raids you're just you're just
sitting in one place
uh with our bus and debuffs together
that's right the fact that
this guy literally kicks the crap out of
people
and dashes at them like that is like
some of the coolest thing i've ever seen
bungie ever done so
um
and then we go to um
number one last wish you know oh
let travis don't say it again explain to
travis why
uh
i gotta spice it up damn it
but this this is without ribbon cheese
by the way because like i feel like
i feel like if that was not there like i
i feel like that would have been like
the best rate for me but like
but um but no but the fact that um
we're fighting like a big old witch
dragon and it has like it's the most
like mechanically driven and that's
pretty much the reason why i like last
week you're mechanics
i i do love mechanic heavy raids
that's just
um
no hate to um
and then crown of sorrows oh wow
we've heard that a couple times recently
yeah what's up
crown number three we gotta know
oh okay
so number three it's just uh i think
it's um like just like the the second to
last encounter then the boss the way
like you know we out here just killing
stuff to get a uh i guess you go inside
the uh if i remember correctly like you
go inside the thing you get like the
buff and like it it's more like team
coordination anyway so yeah um that's
pretty
i
i kind of get a feeling it's like the
whole trading back and forth the buff
and the synergy of you of this one
everybody get ready rotate it over and
has that it when it's a well-oiled
machine
i can definitely see why because when
it's smooth it's good but if you're
learning it man it's chaos it's just
absolutely a mess but yeah if it's if
it's smooth and you gotta get people to
run i definitely love doing that
flawless that was like my favorite
flawless rate oh that's there you
go okay absolutely yeah i used to do it
all the time um
get people to um there are they shadow
titles
that was always a cool title i was i was
like i like the name of that titles like
i knew i was i kind of gave up getting
it and i knew king's paw was going to
come out king's fall is a great ring
they could the king's fall people gave
before taking the chat he was like
king's fault he with you though he
people are saying crown was unique
they're saying it man
people give him some crown a lot of love
now now that it's going i mean that
first encounter was rough but everything
else was great yeah the opening was that
was my day one experience was like i
think it was like six seven hours in
that opening counter we just couldn't
get by it because it was just like a
random group thrown together for i don't
even remember i don't remember who was
there at the time but that opening
counter it was just long enough
and especially like ammo economies and
stuff back then were not quite the same
if you weren't used to working together
and those types of things crown was
ground was the struggle for sure but i
mean i do like i mean val has definitely
set a good bar between i mean we talked
about this it's definitely jumped really
high on my list because as you said
final boss where you're not standing
still amazing aesthetic it's got the
dungeon feel where you start and you can
see where you're going in the end once
you get to that ending encounter and
then you got like a you know balance of
mechanics and bosses and some people
would say it's not enough bosses but i
was like that's kind of a debate but
i was like overall for me it's like i
get i understand the
the rock fight really has
made whatever we get in the future
something like to set a bar for yeah
because
is
[Music]
i think everyone agrees that the roke
fight is good and i would agree that the
caretaker fight is really good that's my
shot
yeah i think caretaker's probably my
favorite as well
so
it's got so much going on yeah it's
literally just a boss for me because
[Music]
just just seeing my fire teammates just
like i don't know it still makes me
giggle that um people still get kicked
by him so
go on yeah
just say built in the animation oh
you're down here smack
oh yeah oh yeah it's really the first
and third counter that i mostly haven't
had a problem with
i think cog and i agree that the third
encounter is pretty
mid
four people who like can trade and
manage the rotation if you have more
than like two newbies
it's gonna it's gonna be interesting
especially depending on what they have
to do there's just there's too many
important pieces to that one but again
and this is why it's like and this is
why i raid experiences and i'm just
gonna like i had a good rate experience
and i've had good rate experience
because i've had the team to play with a
lot same thing as like when you go
through
vault for the first time like you did
you got to go through with friends and
stuff and those moments where you get to
have
like a really good experience and you
get that well-oiled machine
moment running and that's when
exhibition for us now it's just like bam
bam bam bam and all of a sudden we're
like we're done there was one point
where
uh like we were playing and one of the
guys had to go
in like
20 minutes
and we were on exhibition and it was
like our second one of the day or
whatever it was like time we were on
exhibition we're like all right we got
to like flawless this thing and it was
literally just
done got to roll one phase that bam it
just we went out and it's like when you
can run it smooth
oh it feels good though
yeah it does it does
because there's a lot of moving parts to
it and i agree but once that encounter
is smooth you appreciate it more yeah
it's just like i said there's a lot of
could go wrong
it's like if it's smooth it's good if
it's teaching it's a headache so i
totally get that
no
and then the last thing i wanted to ask
um just because it's kind of what we're
in the season of right now is grand
masters
so grand master nightfalls have been
kind of a major challenge the bungie's
put in there and we've had our
discussion about if we do and don't like
champions on all those pieces but grand
masters are
for one one of the ways i met you
um because you pulled me through a very
old conqueror title in a couple days we
knocked out like six
um and that was cool one of your
one of your favorite experiences that
you've got is related to just like
clutching up and then also soloing so
why
for you have grand masters become such
like an integral part of your destiny
experience like what what makes you
enjoy them is there anything that you
would change about them if you could
and then um what's your favorite grand
master that you've done maybe not like
you're you know that one the first one
but like if you have a favorite
nightfall like kind of balance of
challenge and fun
all right well uh i guess like i i
usually use like you know grandmaster to
like you know test certain weapons if
they're actually
okay to use or not but um
i just enjoy it i uh especially solo
just for like like the challenge myself
because um
at first it was just like um
um that first bit like um
where i had to um
where i had to fight a boss in festering
corps like um for
after the timer went out um
um my teammates instantly died and then
i had to
deal with a
a cyclops stack and one shot me yeah um
the ball stack and tether me and and a
bunch of hive nights um
but yeah um i think at that at that
point cuz like i wasn't really into like
gm's when i was doing it but like that
that sudden rush
that i have to just um
find the best build for myself
was like a pivotal reason now i i like
doing the stuff solo so like um
i remember just um
just shooting this boss for 20 minutes
just shooting
i had no heavy nothing all i had was a
super and
i i think it was like probably 10
percent i was like you know what i don't
care i literally pop super and
i almost got them and then
you know i and then i just bowed the uh
yeah just bowled him to death and
and that sudden rush i think
when i did that that day it was just
unattended i just didn't want to give up
that's just something that i
that's something that's like about me is
that like i just don't like giving up
when the going gets tough because um
i dealt with tougher irl
and i'm like
it was a video game i was like i wonder
if i can do this
and when i when i did do it
like that sudden rush
um
just told me like hey you know you know
i should have probably sold gm's one day
i i was just so excited to do one and
um
so i guess one of the first gm's and it
is my favorite gm that i love doing oh
when it comes around it is doubles
layers okay nice okay yeah so um
basically for the music
and stuff like that um
i remember
just going in because you know you know
i watch a lot of um you know some solo
videos from some
some content creators and you know i i
was like you know what i can probably do
that too you know so
mm-hmm
sort of esoteric so that he bought his
video i could do that
yeah like you know it was a great master
so i remember just um in there just
struggling struggling struggling but
again i just do not give up
um
i remember
um just going in there just
and i was just like the i feel like gm's
had really like just
put a highlight into like my career
because you know people see me do a lot
of it
and
but uh i guess the one thing i will
change is overloads because i feel like
they are just one of the most
inconsistent things to stun you know um
usually like when i'm helping people or
just myself like um
[Music]
but i'm just like helping people like
myself like i always like to the
minotaur just smacking me even though
i'm shooting
at them yep
look man i i don't even find it this is
what i fell in love with stasis
i was like i could just freeze you
and you're gonna you're gonna stop
moving around you're gonna stop instant
energy
i had such an appreciation for stasis
with grand remasters and all that stuff
came out because i don't know how you do
it man say i don't know how normal
people
deal with this with powers of the light
like they are the most inconsistent
annoying thing and then the hit doesn't
register
this season is honestly i hope
that either take feedback listen or if
enough people can disagreement from
there after it's overloads with auto and
smg
i hope it never happens again it is the
worst weapon for it
like barriers unstoppables i just
personally think of the unstoppables
with or the overloads with auto and smg
is just
not fun because you're usually because i
was just doing a random last sector too
and it's
you either have as you said a minotaur
chasing you
that's an overload a knight that's
usually trying to shoot you in the face
multiple times or it was actually taken
hobgoblins
that every time you shoot them and hit
them they hit back and you're trying to
hit them about 12 times to stun them
with an auto rifle
and no i just can't stand it so i'm
hoping because like a bow
just think
hand cannon depending on the range but
like
there are better options for overload so
i hope they don't do auto rifle and smg
again or give us some other exotic
options because right now the only one
is divinity
i mean you've got other variations
because like even this season even in
the season i just do not i mean auto
rifles i'm probably okay with but smg if
i'm not playing osseo shrieker i am not
using that
yeah that's the only one it is is very
inconsistent because i feel like and
that's the thing like uh i but the my
favorite overload stunt is bo
by absolutely yeah
just simply like monarch you just shoot
them in the head one time you know get
get a little emo get your little
exercises
little tick damage go off
get a little cardio in between stuns
no well yeah but but as far as like the
other champions like uh they're
they're not too bad i mean yeah uh
unstoppable um
[Music]
unstoppables urges
when i look at unstoppables they're just
they're just something just like oh this
thing all right let me just stand out
the way yeah right right over well they
also they're they they never get their
health back that's the big one right
and then barriers
outside of like teleporting behind
pillars and starting over they're
usually not as bad
so yeah i was like i agree like
overload's for sure the worst
yeah like it's just it's just a minotaur
especially when i play glassway
[Music]
yeah that was a brutal
yeah
i've seen people just like sitting up
somewhere just like
waiting for their opportunity to work on
somebody in glassway and then you sneeze
the wrong direction and you're dead so
yeah oh yeah
especially when the minotaurs like to
boom you but like as far as like you
know champions i don't mind champions um
i know why they're there um
but it's just
um
because i know they they took a pass on
overload sng and auto and i feel like it
was just not enough no um
um i just feel like there needs to be
more
things done but i just
me that's why i've been using the uh the
warlock boots uh which one oh those are
amazing oh yeah it must be nice to have
the first class specific exotic that
deals with champions
they don't use it but is uh artie's
embrace so you just keep getting crits
and you turn your throwing knife to
unstoppable oh
okay yeah okay so titans still don't
have one i guess that's kind of my point
yeah
i had a lot of stuff already this is all
time oh yeah i think titans don't have
one i i don't know if they do but i know
hunters have one but if people just
just didn't use it but oh
but like uh i literally just put down a
riff and then just shoot a gallon and
take it and it's over everything
whatever whatever's in your head is
overload as soon as that riff go down
love it yep love it
and
devour them
no i think that's like the idea of
this is what i want them to get to with
ch with champions is more of a universal
approach to them
like some way to have whether it's a
class ability or
certain certain things that is just a
little more of a you need to do
something to face said champion
but a much more universal approach to it
because
yeah about just how about just an
overload mod that isn't tied to any
speech exactly yeah just yeah yeah
yeah oh
so like more like a mechanic rather than
using a mod
yeah or or i mean i'm an advocate of
them just getting rid of it all together
because i think it's stupid oh okay
i just think like why why
anything that makes me go into my
inventory in order to play better i i
don't want in my game like
this it kind of reminds me of the
problem with uh heavy ammo synths right
it's like
what do you want to do and what's the
last thing you want to do when you're in
a raid oh go into your inventory and use
a consumable well
our entire ammo animal economy is built
around that and now you've got another
part of the game where your entire
ability to even beat an enemy is tied to
you having a specific mod equipped and
uh i i would much prefer them just take
the approach of introduce like
challenging enemies like the uh the
light bearing hive like that's like a
perfect example of what i think they
should be
yeah like like they're they're a
formidable enemy that you have to like
change your play style for and they can
stop you up and kill you in one shot but
they're not like i don't have to go to
my menu to kill them to crush their
ghosts you know
i don't have to i don't have to uh do
something insane like that so i just i
wish they would they would do that
because i i'm just over champions it was
it was a cool gimmick for one season but
it's been like multiple years of me
dealing with these guys and every season
there's new rules about how exactly i
kill them and i'm just i'm sort of over
it yeah hopefully i feel that yeah the
other one somebody else mike g said in
chat he's like barrier servitors
shielding things around them and it's
that moment and they haven't done it as
i haven't seen it as much but
and again believe me i'm with travis
it's like
make different enemies don't just make
these
menu mod socket type enemies which is
you know
do this thing equip this one mod to be
able to progress in this thing it even
says it in the damn directory before you
boot the activity but barrier servers
when they would be shielding like an
overload champion that you have to kill
and you're like all right so i'm being
pummeled by this overload captain who's
just
constantly doesn't he never has to
reload ever do do you how what's your
clip size that's on infinite cool good
to know and then you have to deal with
the champion while you're being pummeled
and then when you break the shield
you're doing some damage to him he gets
back up and then he teleports behind a
wall and you got to start the process
all over again
so
while we're on the topic of annoying
enemies can we also maybe make the scorn
not be able to disappear for 45 minutes
and file their taxes while they're
invulnerable and then decide to go back
into the game and fight me when they
feel like it can we chill with that
maybe for a second and dumb scorn the
the the sniper duels that oh
they're like by frame right there their
damage is broken yeah they said that
yeah yeah they are they are painful
mm-hmm
so what else we got going on
yeah so
we got two ways to go
oh what were you gonna say
i don't know oh i i know if i would miss
like a question about um like my gm
experience or anything
uh as far as the um no you you killed
that i saw that clip and i was just like
the whole team is dead
this man is running around fighting for
his life yes with this bull
and hiding behind the rocks they could
have killed you about the right thing i
can't believe you got it
just went in for it yeah yeah that was
ballsy and salute to you for that that
that is someone that i i get the
mentality because i'm not i'm not a gm
person but i understand uh
if if you if you hear what i say after
my uh after i did complete it uh it's my
it's my alert
yeah i saw the clip man it was really
cool and i i get it from pure challenge
perspective it's an adrenaline rush
especially as a solo player you know
when you solo that it's it's it's insane
so i i get it yeah
i just want a little better reward save
that's all i for all that blood sweat
like it's because like for me
because like to me i always been like
like this solo player in this game
where like you know like i just
you know if i don't have like people to
play with uh you know i like to show
like like you know like my prowess i
would say yeah i mean although i don't
need to prove to anybody but myself i
just flex that flex that emblem flex
that solo
i just want to you know see like what
what works and what doesn't work and
that's why i just keep going in every
week you know
not fair now i have a few souls under my
belt and some of them i still haven't
done but
um at the end of the day like um first
and of course i love the loot inside of
gm's um
oh this is the first i need to hear this
um yes
um
because i know in the beginning of
you know when they when they first came
out it was just like ordinary nightfalls
yeah yeah yeah
um they gave out the same thing and
that's when bungie put up that first
patch without you get like an ascended
shard now you know for every time you
did it and now that
you know it basically incentivize well
my cell phone to just keep going
so
like um and then like you know you know
gm's gotten to like a whole bunch of
changes so like uh
you know when the depths wasn't like
guaranteed and then they start
guaranteeing yeah they increase the rate
yep yeah like well yeah like every time
all you have to do is get platinum
completed boom you're getting a depth
and a shard
and then who knows who knows if you
don't have like the mods for yet i mean
they get your depth mods right um
but yeah i love just going in because
like my ball is always a mess in gm
season because i have so many shards
inside my postmaster oh you eat man
yep and sometimes i forget to turn on
farming mode and i lose shards i mean
but yeah
yeah like um like uh i would do this
over
um any content in the game
better than rates you know because
okay
okay
okay over over dungeons
oh yeah
wow
i love dungeons too i love soul and dunk
yeah wow this is a gm guy i respond
i think that first one hooked him and
then he got that solo in and that's just
that's the thing yeah yeah yeah that
that's that's basically it like that
first one like i did was a fire team and
then you know i didn't know people solo
gm's and i got into that space
and
i started you know loving it and doing
it more and the reason another reason
why i do this like this is like more of
a personal thing for me
is that um if i ever were to be in a one
uh a zero life situation
i i know i can like do it you can catch
up you know you know try to believe in
myself and not try to be
the the angry person that gets mad at
somebody that like you know
um
can't do it you know like because i had
i have many people like that in my time
is that man they just feel so sorry that
uh they they basically waste all the
resist and then i'm just sitting here
like i got you and you know that's
what's up it's nice to be if you're
trying to help people through something
it's nice to have the
confidence knowing no matter what
happens
you're going to get through it and
that's actually yes
i guess like if i if i do my best to uh
make sure they're as comfortable as as
possible
then yeah because i remember i have just
uh one person i won't name him but like
he was
just awesome
in my head like um we was doing uh
what was it
it was gm
oh it was it was uh double slayers he
was just he was just he was
he was literally crying they fell oh my
gosh i was so bad oh wow and
because he you know and he was just
telling me i'm like it's okay i got you
and
and i remember
um
um i remember just uh
you know the boss was at last health and
i was playing you know titan at the time
and
um
and this was like all stream i didn't
tell nobody this story uh this is
something that um i kept
but um
um this i remember um i guess like
suffix you know
he one shot at me i mean i i mean i cuz
like there's like a corner inside of
that room uh where i get to stand in and
yeah a lot of ads yep what's up that's
how you manage that room and you know
uh i remember uh i was one shot um
trying to shoot every single one of my
um
every single one of my snipes in my
bowls
and i just thunder crashed and
did it
damn
yeah and he was just so thankful and
it
like he was you know
and it made me smile knowing that um i
you know helped that guy uh yeah
finished it and you know
i salute to you absolutely you do you're
doing a good thing and at the end of the
day
there's a side of the community destiny
is a game that does require a lot of
activities to have friends and there's a
side of the community that you
highlighting that is real which is there
is a
toxic elitist side sometimes that
doesn't want to help or wants to put
down people who can't complete something
and you can tell what you did for that
for that player your fellow guardian he
was appreciative because he probably in
his heart to himself and i've been there
before you're like i'm never gonna get
that activity done so it's just never
gonna happen i throw my hands up you
know and forget it and
i remember like for one for me was like
dungeon eve was like i remember it was a
shattered throat i was like i never get
there don't worry about it he was like
no no come on i got you and i was like
all right he was just have me in the
backpack he's like all right cox stand
there do this okay we're gonna go over
here we're gonna shoot this i was like
for real we gonna do this like and i
just
for me there's certain content that i
know that i just gotta be honest i am
not skilled enough to be able to do it
on a certain level so that's where a
good sherpa comes in and what you're
doing is very important because it gives
people confidence it makes them happy
that yo i could get i could acquire some
blue and you know somebody i want to
talk about the whole sherpa topic
because like um can i i've seen i've
seen my fair share
and and i have to constantly remind
myself to uh
you know man just keep like keep a level
ahead you know when you're helping
people because at times you know i i did
make mistakes you know so
i just want to let you know i am human
you know yeah
yeah like you know like
everybody gets frustrated yeah i was
like everybody's gonna have the moments
and everybody's gonna yell at me all the
time
for
you know they keep them calm and you
know just like um
and i tell people all day you know i
mean i shoot a lot of drags i will get
you through this
if you ever want a really challenging
endgame activity i recommend trying to
do
literally any activity in destiny with
destiny gary
[Music]
that will that has broken some of the
best
that is disney
yes
he's one of my co-workers and
yeah he'll make he'll make the activity
a thousand times more more challenging
so recommend that if you ever
you ever get to that point
like my clan giving me crap for it yeah
they're giving a hard time look i i
there's certain things i accept that i'm
not as good as others in you know i know
my strengths but and i try not to have
ego my my job and i think travis being
you had this discussion is kind of
lighten the mood
right lighten the mood we know we're
doing something difficult we know it's a
raid one you know day one or whatever
and and that's what you do but i
appreciate what you're saying about
shirt but it's something that people
don't don't talk about so i really
appreciate what you're doing in the
community for that it's pretty dope
so before we get into the 12 which was
one i was actually excited to um except
one moment where i literally stopped
mid-sentence but we'll get to that
because travis is gonna have a
very fun entertaining moment but before
we get to there um there was a tweet
that was put out
and dmg actually had a little thread to
follow and i just kind of wanted to get
you guys thoughts as of playing a decent
amount iron banner where crucible's at i
know we've all had some iron banner
experience recently just to kind of see
because i know some people have been
asking this a lot i guess that's
basically every season it comes up and
finally they were just like yo um
so uh somebody named gamesager don't
know who it is somebody on twitter i'm
willing to bet literally anything that
arena shooters are dead and the
implementation of skill [ __ ] skill
based matchmaking 2.0 are identically
correlated uh arena shooters aren't bad
the games themselves are great we're the
most popular for decades it's the
matchmaking that have killed them and
dmg finally just was like all right i'm
gonna respond
and he got out here and was just like
hey just to keep the record straight we
literally turned off skill-based
matchmaking in the majority of crucible
playlists multiple years ago
this was thanks to feedback from high
skilled players we now have more
negative sentiment around matchmaking
than ever before this is not only coming
from high-skilled bands but many in
low-skill bands who are frequently
matched against players way out of their
punching weight how i feel sometimes in
my solo trials experience
new players are thrown into the fray
with little to no experience in the game
system there is indeed valid feedback to
the team in team distributions here
never feels great to have lobbies
balanced in such a way where your entire
team has a negative kd while yours is
high
that said without skill based
matchmaking the system cannot perfectly
allocate skills across teams
we're passing the feedback up and the
team is looking at future opportunities
for improvements but i wanted to be
clear we do not use skill based
matchmaking in the majority of crucible
playlists we check this every season
when players ask if it was turned on it
was not
um and then frosty i guess it's
frostbolt uh in regards to the negative
sentiment uh yeah because i can match
uh because the matchmaking is just worse
but we can't ignore the other issues
that make pvp feel worse experienced
than before imbalances in pvp no content
it's easier to complain about
matchmaking though so i mean people like
fall off on a tirade of things like that
but the big thing is
i
i go through and play
trials freelance
and it's nice i hope freelance is
something that gets to be more and more
permanent because i know they're putting
it in rotation more it's nice that i can
go in and have the solos and not be
against the three stack
um
and then this weekend was an interesting
topic with the
you know the confidence card getting a
depth loot even though you weren't
flawless which is a debate for another
day but mostly i just wanted to see what
your guys experience were
with basically just any pvp that you
guys play in destiny how it feels when
you jump into iron banner in freelance
and like one time you're gonna go 150 to
75 one time you're going to go 75 to 150
and another time it's like 149 to 150.
sometimes you get those even matches
that are like sweaty the whole way
through and you're like this actually
seems like it was bounced at other times
you're either getting stomped or you're
doing the stomping and you know when it
rains it pours even when i'm an okay
player and all of a sudden when other
people are doing well i'm getting more
kills too so it's like i even had a damn
good guys like i had a 3.25 kd and i'm
like i'm not that good but just like
everybody was dying on the other team so
it just happens that way uh i just
wanted to kind of get you guys thoughts
on i know skill based matchmak making is
this
you know very crazy thing to talk about
in general it always tends to open a
whole big can of worms but i was curious
i was like i was i don't know why it
does because i i i i yeah so i was like
we'll travel so that's what i was gonna
say let's travel ready would you guys
like to see
any some none all
where do you guys feel like skill basing
skill based matchmaking do you feel like
it belongs
in crucible and if so where and to what
extent so anybody who wants to take it
yes i'm gonna i'm just gonna go off here
yes skill-based matchmaking should be in
in uh
pvp it should be in
every mode it should be in every game in
every mode and i i think people
uh
just have bad memories of
destiny has a lot of problems with the
way that it does
lobby balancing and matchmaking in the
past but that doesn't mean that the
systems are wrong it just means that
maybe they haven't gotten the exact
formula or right or or whatever but the
idea behind skill based matchmaking as a
philosophy should exist because
there's two there's basically two things
that could happen one you can do
skill-based matchmaking and you can get
a lobby of people that you think are all
roughly the same skill level and then
you can try to put them on teams and
make them fight each other and the
result is typically that you will
end up with
a pretty close match because everybody
in the lobby is in the same level of
skill the alternative is you do not have
any sort of skill-based matchmaking and
then the lobby has just a whole bunch of
different power levels and the problem
with with when you put all those
different power levels as one lobby is
that it becomes impossible to balance
that lobby
the the distances between the skills are
so high that when you try to sort people
and you do the dodgeball draft pick
right then then you end up with people
who are like this person on my team
sucks and this person my team is a god
and and it just makes it makes it wild
and so i think you need skill-based
matchmaking to make the lobby manageable
because another thing people complain
about all the time is oh lobby balancing
is terrible in destiny well of course
it's terrible it wouldn't be good unless
you have skill-based matchmaking it's
impossible you're asking them to to fix
you're saying hey i don't want
skill-based matchmaking but damn your
lobby suck it's like of course they suck
it's impossible you're you're basically
just like you know drawing people out of
random pools in life and putting them on
a baseball team sometimes you're gonna
get you know an mlb player and sometimes
you're gonna get your grandpa across the
street and it just that isn't happening
but yeah that's not how you do a game of
pickup basketball people have to show up
to the court and i feel like
uh the way that they're doing it is is
insane to me so if you're if your
problem is with skill-based matchmaking
but you think that they should balance
lobbies better you're living in a dream
world that's never going to happen you
need skill-based matchmaking to make the
lobbies even even close to attainable so
i get why people push back on it it
sucks if you're really good and you're
only playing against other people who
are good but there's ways around that
you can do ranking systems you can have
you know certain modes like trials where
it's based on your your where you're at
in your card there's there's other
things to do but philosophically there's
no way to balance a lobby without
skill-based matchmaking and that's what
that's why destiny's lobbies feel so bad
and everybody feels it so that's my rant
no it's a valid point i'm actually
not too far off from you you know um
i've never been anti-skill based
matchmaking the the issue is this and we
got to be we got to be real as a
community right
a lot of times when it was in place
which i don't mind it's just that it
would affect certain people in certain
regions based on their connection and i
think that's where some of the vitro and
the pushback came back so the dmgs
dealing in those points they were like
look
you guys as a community said you didn't
want this
you guys as a community said the
connections are terrible
prioritize connection over everything
so they did
and he told you
so if they did and he told you and the
connections for the most part are great
you can't complain now that yo the lobby
i mean for the most part you know what
i'm saying
for the most part but you know what i'm
saying over compared to how it used to
but you can't complain like yo why they
matching me with this or why my team
sucks or why they put because it's not
on a skill based system so
theoretically is there a way they could
do but i'm not a developer i don't know
you know i don't know if they can
incorporate some type of hybrid for that
you absolutely can and it's it
i think i think uh connection should
always be a factor the question is is it
the determining factor right is it the
is it the biggest factor and i think
sometimes bungie finds itself in a tough
position because their player base is
spread out correct times it's large and
the playlist right right and and it and
you know they've got so many playlists
and i think right managing that is a
challenge but mm-hmm that is the
question yeah that is the the fair
question by the community is if you can
you can do that from an algorithm
standpoint and make it fair on both
sides the only
thing i would say
from because i just look at halo right
the only time i don't there's only one
scenario where i don't want skill-based
matchmaking and that's like
in a quick play slash mayhem scenario
where it's not mayhem like yeah
yeah it's not this is this is just come
in have fun
you know
do get your little three matches of
pinnacle or whatever and going with your
business but if if we're doing iron
banner if we're doing
trials in my opinion yeah it should
exist the players should be matching up
against players of similar skill and to
me it's supposed to be the competitive
mode so
that's where
i differ from you is
quick plays an experience they shove you
to every every single person who jumps
into this game we already talked about
the new player experience being
questionable at best you come into this
game as a new player and you are already
pretty lost generally most of the time
you're like hey here's crucible
i think this is the pvp thing here's the
big thing in the middle that is control
and if they are new
probably don't have a great loadout
don't know their abilities that well
definitely don't know synergies and mods
and anything else
they go in and there's no skill based
matchmaking at all
and you take that player
we're gonna put them as like put them as
a number one for skill
and then you've got
any content creator can think of they're
setting up their 10 11 12 just god to
your skill and somehow those two are in
the same match and they're on the
opposite sides of the ball
and they have the worst experience
getting stomped on and they see somebody
go like 40 and oh
as i literally see tweets of that happen
every hal so often
that is the point to where
i think some needs to be even in quick
play
now again the hybrid like connection
as travis said needs to be a factor but
it's like i shouldn't be on all modes
well it's like but like maybe not quite
as extreme like iron banner like is
almost what we would look like iron
banner and then trials and if we can
ever get comp like to a really a tighter
skill takes a little longer to find
matches everybody was always worried
about these like matchmaking times i'm
like if you take like one or two more
minutes to get a match but that matches
that 10 minute match is much more
enjoyable
aren't you going to enjoy that
but that's the problem and to push back
on your pushback is that
they do this and then the community the
connection's not good oh it takes too
long to get in the match so it's like
the community they can't have it both
ways i get that believe me i understand
that the community at some point is
going to have to give and be like we got
a little and what i was trying to say is
like something like quick play you just
don't like there should not be outliers
a one should not be sharing with the ten
like one through six or seven and a
range in between there but if a brand
new person should not face a true
vanguard in the same match
for like a good while those should not
even be in the same game
because if you're fighting against them
it's like that's not going to be fun for
that person
and it's like okay wait a little bit
longer and fine and again if it's like
there's not that many playlists right
now
we haven't introduced that many modes
that you've got classes enough though e
because i would say to cogs point of
they can't have it both ways well they
could the question is is it worth it
what if what if quick play was one
button that just put in all the modes so
sometimes you get scorched and sometimes
you i would like that too and like what
if they did that what if it would have
increased
they could do that to kind of put all
the modes in one bucket that's actually
kind of how halo does it they have fewer
playlists but there's more modes in like
one of their playlists and and that that
keeps all of the player base in kind of
one area um so i think they could do it
it's just a question of like what are
the what are their player counts can
is is the only way to do it to put them
into one mode or is that worth it to
them or do they really care about pvp as
a whole i think those are the questions
that
to me that's the the fact that they have
a system that they know doesn't work
they said hey skill bit matchmaking has
been turned off for several years and
it's now the complaints are worse than
they've ever been and they haven't
changed it
right like
they are sort of admitting that this is
the worst situation they've ever had and
they haven't changed it and so i i just
think i'm just glad they're talking
about it because to me as soon as
skill-based matchmaking turned off i was
like are you insane like why why would
you do that isn't it always better if
people are playing with people around
their
here's the thing people players can
complain
sometimes they don't know what's good
for them though
sometimes fans are just wrong sometimes
fans are just wrong and i i mean i i
love that bungie listens to their
community but i'm a big fan of not
listening to the kids i'm telling you
right now
the connection not to cut you the
connection stuff i hear exactly what
you're saying the connect i remember it
was such
they got because of the
match times and they were like i don't
want everything to be a sweat fest i
remember these talks and they push hard
on them okay can i say something about
that i don't want everything to be a
sweat fest thing let's go it's elitist
that's that's the short way to say it we
do it yeah it is it was it was all
streamers it was all people that they
shouldn't have been listening to that's
my i'll keep it quiet
oh spicy i get you i'm sorry i feel i
know where y'all going i know where
y'all going
i'm with y'all do it burn it down say it
no it's like the idea that
if you don't want a sweaty match
that means
that likely means not 100 of the time
but that likely means that you are a
high skilled player
and you have
you're going to be playing against
people around your level that are also
good and that are going to challenge you
more frequently
but it's like you the idea the one thing
to say about that is the idea you got to
remember the other 75 of the player base
or more
that is
now if it's not skill based gets crapped
on every match because guess what you
and the high skill players are playing
against people who are just worse than
you straight up worse than you about 75
to 80 of the players in your lobby are
worse than you and yeah that's how you
get to go 40-0 in a match
as opposed to hey things are a little
bit tighter more competitive you get
that 1.9 they got that like you know 0.8
down here and it's a little closer if
you have a 40-0 you probably just like
crapped on somebody's day and they quit
the game like for the day they're just
like i i that dude killed me every time
i woke up today so i'm just gonna shut
it down i'll try again later maybe
anyway uh we've been ranting about this
i know
save you've been very
quiet thoughts on this because you've
definitely done flawless like lighthouse
and i've seen your snipes and stuff like
where are you and all you got to hear
this we got to
educate us where we're wrong
i don't know
i mean i still think uh lobby
matchmaking it is a problem because i
can tell you as much as i you know
sometimes i get to you know be saved to
sniper you know sometimes um
they uh i would go like most a lot of a
lot of those flawless games that i play
um i'm not to like tear up on somebody's
like density or anything i don't know
how bungie does like the matchmaking
when it comes to trials but
every time i lose i get curious and then
um my the opponent's fire team is
stacked like
like my skill of my fire team mm-hmm
um
let's just say joe blowing stevie q
i'm no best player or anything i've
but
usually my fire teams is just like they
they they're like on like 20 lost win
streaks
and they thought this was a good matchup
for you to go against
team elite
no that's okay
i can go off like like a few games or
something like that and then i get to
these games i'm just like
just
why
i don't know because like my chat that's
the thing is
this is exactly why skill-based
matchmaking would help it because it
would make the lobby yeah i mean like
balance yeah to me me personally like um
i don't care who they put on my fire
team
but
i guess
and that's why i say like the whole
matchmaking problem is that like
they're putting me my fire team members
they're like so low to the spectrum
to where
like i'm not going to like you know dog
power on
not shooting a bullet or
where they are because you know i
sometimes i just like i just i'm just
like uh
but yeah
but as far as me uh pvp and stuff like
that i'm i'm okay i'm just i've just
been chilling i've been i've been
embracing the meta lately so
uh i think uh last weekend i was just
fusioning
the crap out of people
and then if i saw uh my favorite titans
you know you know that that uh what's
that uh lordly lordly splendor if i say
that right yeah yeah yeah that advantage
you know i'm just sitting in a little
wrist with that thing i hate you
you can just kiss right off man oh oh
now that's what there's more powerful
than turrets now should we do anything
no no i hate your time
i mean every time i played a team like
that
see for me i stopped numbers i usually
go vortex or if i'm going solo i throw a
little you know solar grenade extended
duration just kind of burn them out you
know you burn them out with continuity
by anti-titan buildings if i need that
um
funny that says just play gamet i i
remember i used to be so into gambit
i'll tell you
i'm wrecking their day gambit oh
them triumphs ooh it was real
yeah that was that was a grain in half
and that's just one of those i would
love to get like
a i would love to find enough like
high-level pvp players that were on
different sides of this argument to
actually hear
kind of a legitimate debate because
when it comes to the skill-based piece
i know there are some who are probably
okay with it and those are some that are
absolutely against it and i would be
really curious to know because somebody
in chat said and it actually was an
interesting point imagine call of duty
modern warfare 2 with skill based
matchmaking there would be no nukes and
i'm going
okay i get the idea that kill streaks
are fun to get
but again the fact that you got 25 kills
because you're paired against a whole
bunch of crap people compared to you
does that make
is the satisfaction that you're like oh
i'm better than all these other people
and now i get the kills death streak
that makes it even more
and it exacerbates the issue even more
because you just nuked the entire team
is it
i don't know it's just like is the nuke
is like the fun moment worthy where you
can do that and even in that game it
almost makes more sense to have less
skill-based matchmaking because the kill
streaks are desirable we don't even have
anything like that in this game it's
just your abilities and you yeah and
there's nothing like that to go for it's
just like if you're getting crapped on
every match you go into
and it takes you like four matches to
finally have a decent one you may not
have made it to that fourth match to
have a decent match and you just set it
down
and that's that's a that's a lousy
argument to be honest it's like the only
people who benefit by unbalanced lobbies
are streamers and people who get their
kicks out of just like rob you know
raffle stomping the enemy team and it's
not good game design it's not good pvp
design there can still be kill streaks
and stuff like that you know you get
your super you might get a few kills or
maybe you just get lucky or whatever but
they should be the anomaly the exception
not the rule they shouldn't just
constantly be happening so that one team
is just thoroughly
not enjoying the match and i just think
how do you do that without skill-based
matchmaking you can't just pull a random
sampling of people into a lobby divide
them on teams and think you're going to
get anywhere close to a balanced
setup it's just it's just not
mathematically viable so i i think yeah
the the there's a certain
group in the destiny community that
would very much benefit by their not
being skill-based matchmaking and i
think they're controlling the
conversation for whatever reason and
they shouldn't be
well you know how i felt on it you know
so you just been preaching the stuff me
and even kind of saying during the
flashpoint days to be honest you know
saying we've always we've always been on
this and it's just
you know
again it's uh i hate to say it this is
how i feel i just feel it's a vocal
minority that has a lot of power that
can influence and
you sometimes you have to look at the
overall community the overall health of
the game and to me it it it behooves the
health of the game to play
against people closer to your skill you
know what i mean and that to me makes
you better that to me puts you in in in
better matches and you don't have the
stomps you know what i'm saying and i
get it i don't want to be completely
dismissive i get for people in certain
regions right that
hey their skill is what their skill is
so the algorithm has to search
another country i now that i empathize
with right i empathize the way time or
the connection may suffer for those
people so maybe the the intermediate
thing is kind of what travis says it's
just maybe we put the pressure on bungie
from a hybrid standpoint where you know
like you know like algorithm if this
then this if you're connecting you know
then you go to the next tier of whatever
um you know ranking or whatever this way
the ranking comes back in you know so
it's like
they they have to build it they have to
they have to incorporate it because
clearly there's still a disconnect with
the community to where it is now from
how it used to be and they have to find
that happy medium i don't even i'm not
saying it's easy but you just got to
figure it out i was like i mean i guess
that if you want a mathematical example
because one of you guys said it made me
kind of think of it because i've heard
it referenced this way take a whole
bunch of people like some ones some twos
some threes and a 10. and this is where
you guys talk about the lobby
matchmaking the 10 gets put with
however if they get put on the the 10
with a whole bunch of ones
the average of the others are still
probably going to get more kills but if
that 10 all of a sudden has like a 10 a
four a three a two and a one and then
you only have threes twos ones and a
four and there's nobody on that other
level they have no chance reach right
and that's why the outlier and that's
why i'm saying like the outlier idea
it's like if you're if you go skill
based like maybe on quick play the range
is wider
but a one and a ten should never be in
the same place maybe like you know three
to eight sure you got some because
if you ever want to get better at pvp
you need to play people somewhat close
to you playing people better than you
is a good thing but telling people like
i should never step into a game against
em test i would just get just floor
wiped not even gonna like have a chance
just he's a better fps shooter than i
will probably ever be just as an example
any of those guys probably are that are
high level in pvp i'm gonna lose but i
don't get any benefit out of that
because i don't get to
practice and there's no time for me to
act because i'm typically dead faster
than i know what to do if there's
somebody who's like a tier above and
this is what travis has been asking for
and what i hope is coming in season 19
is ranked if you're in that range of
like i'm in 1800 to 1900 and i'm 1800
but i'm paired against the guy the 1900
guy but we're kind of close but he's
better then i can kind of say okay
here's this i could work on my shots but
i know i'm not going against like 8 900.
i shouldn't be in the same ballpark so
that's all like there could be ranges
and it doesn't have to be and again i
get like if europe is pairing with like
japan over here there is a problem
because the ping is going to be too too
bad yeah absolutely so like that's
that's the idea it's like i get the
connection piece
and in certain places it's it could be
weighted more but if there's zero skill
in the entire game that is that's why
you get the stuff that you do and i
think that i think most people i will
say and every so often i will honestly
say some people in the comments are like
oh travis is this travis is that i've
seen more travis eight lion comments
going through the chat right now i was
like spitting fire right now so i just
wanted to show you
it's real you know i mean i'm consistent
right i'm consistent i've been saying
since the beginning i'm not an elitist i
don't think i'm a one percenter of of
trials i just would like to play with
people in my general skill range and i
that's just i think everyone should play
in the general skill range i think
people who are you know at the 99th
percentile should play in their skill
range and the people that are the super
try hard shirt wherever i end up fitting
in that i'm not i don't claim to be a
god in pvp or whatever but wherever it
is i fulfill in that i want to play
against my peers so that i can get
better and improve and that is the
essence of
competitive multiplayer and that that
just philosophically that's how it
should be and i think uh just over the
years bungie's sort of taken out a piece
here and add a piece here and they've
kind of lost their way of like this
machine that they've built and they
don't really know what to do with it but
i'm really glad to hear them talking
about it because it means hey look
they're going to they're going to
address it season 19 it seems like they
have a plan like this is a conversation
that they've really taken the time to um
to kind of assess and i'm just looking
forward to
them moving the needle in some way
because it's just it's been such a back
and forth in a bad state situation for
so long but yeah
i appreciate the comments that are
supporting me and the ones that aren't
supporting me
it's good to have a discussion it's
totally fine for sure that's part of it
but that's like that's why i would let
like firing range i would love to have
that entire show on here just to see
their thoughts about
and again i don't know if they talked
about it yesterday because it was it was
two days ago they might have talked
about it last night i still need to
listen because they had patty cakes on
last night shout out to pattycakes ultra
nice guy when we had them on oh i love
pacquiao yeah
so
it's just one of those
it is an interesting discussion and i
can see
some of both sides
but again it's like from that high tiers
perspective
it is kind of one of those things that
you have to take a step out of your
i'm ultra skilled box and think about 80
of the other people and it's like and
then it does change discussions but
anywho
so
we got a swab and this is one i was
waiting for because got the tease about
it last week
now
we're mid-april
and
you know it's actually mid-april and
this season i have jury duty next week
by the way i'm not looking forward to
that
i have jury summons on wednesday
oh
i'm in packs
oh next week
um we gotta talk about that man
i think about it
okay well no i have like i have summons
i don't know if i'll get picked or make
it all selection i just i've been
summoned to go down you've been down in
dallas yeah yeah you've been there and
then when i get there it's like i'll see
if i get picked but i moved my date from
like
two days after which queen launch
says i was not going to go then i just
heard it now
but now my number is like so low i'm
definitely probably going to go like
have to see if i'm in selection my wife
actually had to serve on one last week
so
she got picked all the way
um but the big thing is dungeons and
raids so of course fun topic good time
to have our guest on can't ask for a
better one sorry we've been going off on
sbmm so thank you sam for your patience
thank you save for your pace we had to
get that out
appreciate
it i just have one thing to say so
i appreciate you brother all right uh
big thing to know master val of the
disciple is coming tuesday so i know say
you got a new challenge coming you ready
oh yeah always
so it's 1580
um not some people think it might be
1590 but it's 1580.
uh uh i think uh lydiana just tweeted
that that was that people thought it was
a typo and she was like uh not typo
oh the 1580 is real
yeah but but it's just like a plus 30
seasonal cap so
if you're 1590 that's really it so
oh so 15. so if you were 1590 there's
nothing above that is what you're saying
so it's like a soft contest basically i
guess that's kind of a way to read it i
was wondering what the detail of that
was that makes sense um we will be
getting adept versions for the raid
and this is kind of one thing i wanted
to ask before we get into
my actual excited topic
with crafted weapons coming from the
raid now they do take a little while to
get the red frames i've got
i've got about half now not all of them
but at least a couple working on some
more i'm almost
almost to submission and then i think
i've got two others
with crafted weapons being an option now
do any of you guys find adept weapons
the grind for an adept weapon as a drop
now worthwhile
[Music]
do any of us think that they ever were
that's a different question
feel strongly say hey sam has some balls
for me he shocked me what he said but he
felt strongly about it continue yeah
because
um thing i mean i still get them no
matter what the depth weapons but uh
for me
i think um i guess
like crafting it's just
because i i could i guess where are you
really getting for like the devil i
guess you get like that that mods and
you get like
all stats
um when you master work it
um
but i think the only question i have is
that um they did say that uh after each
encounter like you'll get a
you have a chance to get a death drop
and i wonder if they took
those the depth drops that they uh that
you're going to get from challenges
that's just my concern
um
but as far as like they worth it uh
between a depth and
crap um non i'm gonna say no personally
because if i need a gyro i can just go
craft it
um as opposed
but if we if we could i already know
that we probably can't even uh craft a
death weapon so yeah most likely not
it's just
i don't
i'm just it's just it's just a gray area
of me just uh caring about um a debt
weapons where i could just crack my own
weapon like that i think like the weapon
that i have crafted so far is my
cataclysmic uh i have uh
i have uh enhanced uh
four times the charm and focus theory um
if yeah if noah doesn't drop that with
my same role i'm
hey yeah
what about you guys
yeah i mean i'm team crafton um
you know obviously the system's not
perfect
you know i say but we're gonna get to
that we're gonna get to that
we're gonna get to that but look i just
this week
you know i i'm still conflicted about
the the investment right but when i
finally did it i'm like i got my alloys
i got my ruinness my drowned my energy
50k glimmer
whatever shards i'm in the table i i i
stayed
with a terrible roll of peace of mind
you know how playing handicapped with
bad you know stability and terrible perk
and i leveled that bad boy up to 12
because i knew then i could get my range
on masterwork and then i could get the
perks i want i got my enhanced arm
elemental capacitor i was able to get my
perpetual motion on it throwing you know
little um high caliber rounds on that
bad boy
and i'm not gonna front i'm slaying and
it felt so good i it there was a part of
me that gave me
d1 sensibilities and that i committed to
the invested in the weapon yeah and i
put in the work
i stayed with a terrible gun for weeks
through
trials
like that that takes me to a perfect
point though because
crafting isn't perfect and we'll get to
the horrible joke later perfect yeah
it's not perfect oh
yeah it's not perfect it's not right
there's a lot of issues i got
but what i wanted yeah sorry no what i
wanted to ask you is
that system
there
sticking with a terrible weapon just to
get the perks that you want right how
would you guys like to see that
change future seasons whenever they can
get to it how do you think that would
make the process more enjoyable so
you're like because you don't want to
spend extra resources theoretically to
get like the mid level like the seven
and eight perks before you actually just
like let me use this crap thing for like
16 levels and then finally get up there
so how do you think they can make that
more enjoyable but still feel the
investment or
go ahead
no this is a great question and i was
thinking about it during this whole two
weeks of me two three weeks of me doing
this i am torn because there's a part of
me
that says
you should invest
to basically dictate a god role
because we i am circumventing rng
now i have a piece of mind that i got
from a drop that had half of the guard
roll it had for pvp it had elemental
capacity but it had like compulsive
reload i'm like damn i don't want that i
want perpetual motion all i want
whatever right so and it didn't have the
masterwork i wanted
and that gun was good but it wasn't
perfect so there's a part of me that's
like i shouldn't just
easily
be able to just go to the crafting table
and
mix ingredients and and just boom i'm
god roll because now you circumvent so
part of me does like the fact that i
grind it for that and then i put it in
the work god know
what i was gonna sorry it just popped in
my head so i just want to lose my
thought here
so you like the idea of the investment
yeah and you also mentioned you got an
alternate drop
yes so
what if theoretically to unlock the
pattern
and this is again going away from deep
side so there's a whole system change so
i don't expect this but what if you
unlock the pattern
you would have to get a certain number
of kills time spent with activity
whatever you do
you have the drops that you want for
that weapon and then you like
2 000 kills later like a catalyst or
something you actually unlock the base
level
then you can pick all the perks you want
and then your crafted weapon you could
theoretically then spend time and to
invest for the enhanced perks
two flaws to the system you make it a
fantastic point two floor to the system
i don't feel there's too much rng with
acquiring a pattern
right that that part is weird
so that's the part i was going to talk
about cog
i'm almost finished yeah i'm almost
ready that's the part and then the the
biggest beef
with the amount of materials i needed to
get an enhanced version of the perk
right
now that i have it i should have it
i shouldn't be permanent unlock
level 12 or 14 i got enhanced whatever i
now if i want another version of this
and i'm to put the
that part should be unlocked and that
should be no cost already don't double
charge me back at the atm now after i
already made the commitment so that's
why i'm with you i'm finished now i'm
curious to hear what both of you guys
got to say because that was just my
experience
uh yeah i was just gonna say um
for one i don't know that this matters
it's not gonna matter for 95 probably
more than that percent of the destiny
community that isn't going to engage in
the end game for super long after you
know we're done so i think the system by
design is made for the people that are
going to be here for a long time and so
maybe therefore it's okay that it's
grindy i don't know that this is
at the top of or anywhere resembling the
top of bungie's list of stuff that they
should tackle or focus on but um if i'm
criticizing it
as a system
which is sort of my job so of course i
am um i uh
i would disagree with you cog that you
are circumventing rng because what's
happening is it's actually making you do
two grinds and one of them is based on
rng which is how you get the red frames
and so i would say if you can get five
red frames of a single weapon to drop
you sort of have already done your rng
work and you should probably just get
the you know i mean like
in my in my perspective they have to
choose one either i get the
the design right away the pattern right
away and then the grind is leveling up
the weapon or
getting the design is the grind and then
once i the design's done i can craft
whatever i want as long as i have cool
materials to do so and that brings me to
the third grind which is a hidden grind
which is a materials grind and that
materials grind also includes the uh
exotic you know whatever the new
material is
send an alloy send an alloy uh that's
another grind on top of it so i just i
think the question of like oh i'm
subverting rng not really you're just
doing like four mini versions of rng
that maybe feel a little bit more fun
than just grinding the same activity and
hoping for a god roll because the thing
i do like about the system is that there
is an end in sight no matter what like
you know that there's going to be an end
but i would disagree that you're
subverting rng and i think that they
could do a lot to improve kind of uh the
landscape there the only pushback i got
to give you though is ev i agree 90
the only pushback is every single
category i can pick what i want once i'm
unlocked like that's powerful i every
single category i could be like your
arrowhead break high caliber rounds you
know the extra mag
range stability like ev like i am
literally getting the i'm buffet you
know what i'm saying but there is a
power to that there is a but
they're they're taking all the most
powerful perks and making them
non-craftable as well so that they can
leave them for a depth right it's not
like you can craft an adept weapon and
you can apply literally any point they
give you a pick list they give you yeah
they give you a very yeah curated no
good point and i think that they they
take off the table the uh ultra god roll
perfect so they try to get you like most
of the way there but i just think
they're
they're sort of a beauty in what they're
doing because they're trying to have it
both ways where they can have the god
world chase for the adepts for the
people who are in the one percent of
people that do that and then they've got
like maybe this 90 to or maybe a 10
percent that are doing the hardcore
crafting they get you most of the way
and then for everyone else it's just you
know laissez faire or whatever yeah you
get you use um and so i i think there is
a certain beauty to it i just think that
uh they could streamline it it obviously
could be better i think everybody knows
that i mean we're already going to be
talking about some improvements they're
making yeah today with the with those
same you've been very quiet and patient
over there
where are you on kind of your state of
crafting right now just like outside of
obviously when we were talking about
masters and depth crafting
uh
just crafting like just crafting the
weapon or
yeah just the whole crafting system
right now how you would yeah you feel
like anything you said like peace of
mind just to know well they already
dealt with one of my first problems with
materials because um
uh even until this day because uh
that cataclysmic that i was trying to
get with bait and switch
requires rave materials yeah you have to
get a red border and they put even more
of an rng
that you that that red border had to
have a rape perk and i got many red
borders and
uh this has been week four and i could
not i cannot get another rape perk i
just need one to
uh craft my version of uh of another
cataclysmic so i just that's why i just
went with focus fear because i didn't
have the material i'm glad that's going
away but as far as like the whole
getting the materials
like
i feel like it should be another way
like i i really do feel like um
like i i had like an idea in a way but
you know you play with the weapon to a
certain level you make it resonant or
something and then you
level it up to get the materials i mean
that actually
be bad
but the reason why i say this is because
uh my vault is literally filled with
almost like red stuff that i have to
keep
and
i'm and bought is like an issue like you
know
um oh yeah i i i personally don't like
um
i mean i mean people do it you know
spending my time at shirochi getting all
these
that's the spot you like going to the
spot
yep oh no that's yeah i was like that's
the problem is that's what you see about
like leveling up
everybody's like
what they should do is uh give you
so much xp for doing an activity
as a as opposed to because like i tell
you right now and
uh because heavy weapon uh
resonant weapons are a lot easier than
energy and yes kinetic can never be it
takes so long oh that's fine it's brutal
yeah i feel like the only thing that
like you know in case i don't want to do
cheryl chi all day i i'll probably just
go to those little psyos battlegrounds
and put on three resonance weapons and
him to get it done
yeah yeah
but that's another thing i do in case i
get more but like um
we shouldn't do that like i really do
feel like you know um there should be a
a way we can get these materials without
like you know trying to hoard on weapons
because i know
us as like content creators we have like
many weapons that we want to test out
and stuff like that and
and of course you know like you know
these red borders is
been filling my ball so i guess that's
the only thing i will feel i mean i'm
glad they're taking away
you know the materials next season which
we only need neutron elements but there
needs to be more ways to get new trials
i mean yep
yeah that's the big issue
and that number shouldn't be 200 every
time because
it was like i'm only getting 200 from
mm-hmm
i wouldn't mind if they uh they ever did
patch the shiro chi
uh part just oh dudes they're gonna be
hurting you you're taking like if i just
asked one of my friends back for that
for that spot i said who got the spot
that's what happened
got patched it was like oh yep
how about this save you get 200 for a
primary weapon 300 for special 500 for
heavy
that would be cool
that's my proposal because heavy takes
way longer you guys ever have like a
heavy weapon it's like if you're going
to certainly heavies are actually the
fastest which is weird
i think heavy is the fastest because uh
there's been there have been times like
when i'm in character i'm just shooting
like
40 percent yeah
you're going out of your way
exactly yeah
i'm just like let me go do other stuff
especially if you're doing pvp you're
going to be rolling with that one
exactly and that's in the normal way of
grinding heavies are 100 percent worse
but if you have something that explode
now like casual like cataclysmic
that's a linear that's going to be hard
to do at cerro cheese so that's going to
be a little more natural
i dread snipers when i get one oh yeah
but that's like they wanted to help
vaults and they made them worse because
to craft one weapon and granted once you
craft it
it's fine but like in future seasons of
season 17 we're gonna have new craftable
weapons they said they also may be
bringing
older weapons into the crafting as well
we don't even have a hand cannon in
crafting right now which
actually blew my mind a little bit when
i saw that the first time because this
game is built around hand cannons but
it take to get two enhanced perks it
would take you doing 20 red outline
weapons to get two enhanced perks that's
insane
i mean and if you go through so it's
like if i want what five enhanced
weapons with enhanced perks on each that
is a hundred red outline weapons and
that's not me investing time in the
weapon that i like that's me using all
these crap red outline weapons to get
this material resource that i have to
spend it on it's that
i'd
we are definitely in weapon crafting
like bait i can't even talk like right
now we're in weapon crafting
the more i think about it the more i get
frustrated that because we already knew
we were about to have 50 currencies
we did get one more we'll get to that so
the 50 currency
or that oh that was i love i love when
they just introduced duke because i'm
here for travis i'm like what are they
going to do i can't wait till we get to
the other section but when they were
talking about that one i was like yo
he called it that was the funny part
and you guys all thought i was insane
and let us not forget the only reason
they didn't is because of technical
limitations yeah
girls like
and also like usability i'm like they
can't put like five sorry bungie if you
guys are listening to this we love you
but yeah this is
one
um
but yeah it's like they can't find a
place to put five currencies displayable
right now that we have
50 would have shut the servers down i'm
pretty sure we would have broken things
but yeah this is
i like the idea of investment
in the weapon i want to like invest into
this
doing all these other things
just to get invested in this and then
you still got to spend the 20 years with
this weapon to level it up to level 20
or 30. if you want to use your mementos
except that nightfall one that's a
traffic cone if i can make one more joke
basically move on
yes yeah yeah
one more new rad uh has been saying for
weeks that pvp is holding destiny back
in the comment section
you know what apparently technical
limitations are holding destiny back
you should then you should thank pvp for
being in the game because if they
deleted it right now you know it would
replace it 50 crafting currencies
you're welcome pve players you're
welcome oh no i i tell you like i
although i talk about reading a lot too
uh
i used to play a lot of pvp and d1
me too i used i used to do trials
carries yep
nice
i'll get you back into it one of these
days once they fix things we'll get you
back into it
crafting tangent aside that was
accidental but
a good discussion thank you all
we are going to be getting something new
in season 17. we are going to be getting
a new rotator system for
seasonal challenges which is going to
basically work as it does right now and
then we're also going to get weekly
categories for raids and dungeons and we
have been asking for this for so long
so each season is going to work kind of
as it does now the most recently
released raid currently valid the
disciple and the most recently released
dungeon which in season 17 we will get a
new one
shout out to that because we don't know
what it is yet
those are going to be pinnacle drops on
every encounter as they are now pretty
standard pretty much what we got going
on
if you take season 18 for example we're
supposed to get a new raid then that's
when valve the disciple would go into
the weekly rotator and the new raid
would be the you know seasonal pinnacle
all drops or pinnacles
the weekly rotation now is going to be
anything not in the seasonal that we
just mentioned is
dungeons are going to have a weekly
rotator and raids are going to have a
weekly rotator
now rewards are going to be pinnacles
from the end
so a pinnacle from the final drop so if
you're doing your seasonal grind if they
keep it at 10 power level that'll be one
more thing you can rotate in there
it's also going to be featured which is
nice you actually see kind of a
featured place for raids to kind of be
focused up that'll rotate them through
but they're also going to be 100
farmable there's going to be no cap that
means if you want to run last wish 20
times in one week you're going to be get
legendary drops from that raid
every drop
or every encounter no matter how many
times you run it so if you run 20 raids
and there's five drops per raid you can
get a hundred drops in that week if you
want to
what's up does this 100 drops include 1k
voices i have dj orals for the chat
who's been trying to get me this gun for
for months does that can we get a fine
print on i don't know if exotics are in
there but in theory
talk to me hopefully uh i'm going to say
before we answer that question god i
would hope so with old raids though
because i need to do that you want it to
be farmable because that sounds like a
nightmare i feel like it's a blessing
that you can only run it three times a
week and get the chances
do you want like literally if they told
you oh yeah you can get it now
just depends how much you want to play
it i'm gonna be real with you i did that
for anarchy you wouldn't want the living
crap
that wasn't that one wasn't unlimited
farmable if they told you hey you could
get anarchy faster you just got to play
it 100 times in one week would you
that's what they did with anarchy that's
what they did
with anarchy yeah it was unlimited and
capped
right right before they took it out of
the game
before they took it out i got you gotcha
i was in there we was i do all of that
i'll tell you yeah i gotta say okay oh
yeah oh yeah i'll tell you i
helped so many people do that remember
that
we was in it it was like we had a conga
line it was like yeah
uh there are people whose farm spoils
like me
yeah like when i get a chance
but also
why would they do that right before they
took the raid out because then that
doesn't that mean that they were just
about to sell it in a machine i mean
they put it at the kiosk but if you
wanted to put around the raid
they were like all right here you go
because
it could be
look at it this way let's try it's funny
look at it this way trav think about
your pain that you had
with what's the rocket launcher from
from deep stone yeah but if they told me
hey in two weeks we're gonna sell it in
a vendor or you can grind it one hundred
times i would be like
wait you gonna go for walmart
yeah that's insane i feel like bro i'm
i'm cool i'll just wait till you just
saw the story they had that going for a
while though it wasn't like three weeks
before it was a while it was for like
almost the whole season it was for a
good chunk of time
um i still i was like well you they
specifically said legendaries encounter
for legendary gear being removed so
exotics do sound like they're gonna be
weekly i'm guessing
so i would i would honestly be okay if
it was in there because last wish is
three years old that's what i'm saying
let me eat divinity's a quest
deep stone crip's already a year old if
you want to farm that checkpoint 20
times and you've like at that point
you've mastered the encounter again
that's why i was like i want to cap on
this stuff anyway so i'm just fine with
it yeah e this dragon don't worry i
would like to add
uh whatever last wish becomes that that
seasonal rotator it is going to be a
farming simulator
i'm telling you right now i don't even
think people are going to be doing full
encounters anymore they would just go
jump into the checkpoint who got the
checkpoint who would the belly of the
beast
be like yo i'm gonna go ahead and just
go get my weapon screw the whole way so
it's like so tyranny of heaven drops
here all right everybody go we're to
fight hot take i think that they should
be able to do that on any raid
i think that mechanic of the mechanic of
being able to jump to whatever encounter
you want i think you should be able to
do that on any raid because it's insane
to ask a community to like oh you have
to get to the end just if you want to
shout out at the the last item and
people find workarounds anyway they
share people
and so so what what is the point of that
if there's if there's ways to get around
it anyway you should just
you should be able to pick your
encounter from the menu when you're in
orbit yeah maybe maybe if you've beaten
the raid before yeah maybe it's tied to
the title system or something i was like
i would say everybody who's down the
raid you might have to have like beat it
a couple times or something like you
don't want that like put a requirement
on it sure yeah but eventually i could
see that but for like you know first
certain number of clears or something i
don't know if i love that at first
yeah definitely not i would say not not
until
no total perspective
we've had battles on this subject and
he's he's been very clear like you know
like
three to five times and then you could
do it it doesn't need to be 20. okay but
i'm like but yeah i don't want somebody
who's never raided the raid to be able
to be taken to the streets
to be able to take him straight to rogue
like
yeah
yeah no that's what i was like if the
new players in your fire team you got to
run it all but if you've all beat it
like five times and you just want to go
and it's gonna be all the way to the
pass
yeah you'll have an easy pass to run
after five raids sure
i agree with that but
they could just add this mechanic to the
featured playlist so that it doesn't
affect the current rate or the current
rate
why not why not do that we'll see i'm
curious what if the exotics do do play a
factor
that way i can do the one encounter i
need to do to get the uh the uh the
solar um bow and the last wish because
and and to your point try the raid is
old already it's not the new hotness
that is
whatever you're only getting that you
want to pinnacle from it it's old it
could be a three-year-old raid there's
not origin traits which is again that
was probably a big ass call i hope but
it's not there
and then or just or just guarantee
exotic drops after 10 runs i don't know
at least fix the damn orange yeah i mean
give me a cap on that
oh
rng as i i just do not like um rng on
titles that's something that oh
i spoke
uh specifically about because um
i remember not getting vexed
for a whole season it took me 54.
and still don't have i did like all the
i did i did like all the master
challenges
the only reason why i didn't get that
title that season because i didn't have
a vex
dude that that is so important you ran
it you ran it every possible time on
every character oh yeah three characters
i love when i help people and they get
it their first or brawl under 10 tries i
have a friend who would tell you that
you weren't trying hard enough because
you weren't deleting your characters
every week rolling a fresh one and then
doing the raid more than three times a
month sorry if you delete your character
i have i can't i don't know if i can
talk to you like
oh yeah there's no guy who does that
right
secret
he'll just delete his character two of
his three characters i deleted my
characters wasn't it was in d1 and i
just started slip i remember i i did
warlock hunter titan and then i deleted
those two to make three hunters and then
beast yeah i remember the triple just
like you know what i'm gonna go back to
a warlock and type
yeah you know this gets to be a bit much
i forgot people did that
i was like so for me i guess i haven't
totally weighed in
i like the idea of the rotation it gives
freshness to shatter throne prophecy pit
of heresy
and then theoretically grasp of everest
is about to go in this rotator when we
get a new one next season so i like to
have a reason to play those but i also
would like to see them do some type of
refresh to the loot in there because a
lot of loot is older and now with origin
traits it's basically already outdated
for what's in there some of the raid
stuff is exclusive like there's only
solar bow in the game is in last wish
yeah yeah well that's legendary at least
outside of um tikus
so it's like it's good that there will
be you know a little more incentive to
go in there karen get that but it's just
because there's not access to one if you
give me a solar craftable bow i have
little reason to go back to last wish
literally except for the exotic so
while i like the idea of the rotation
and like more people can go solo a
dungeon go for triumphs and things like
that i'll apparently probably be redoing
most of my dungeon guides because there
will be a lot of them oh yeah um
but i am wondering how
how much this will bring to incentive to
play them
if you've been playing for a while if
somebody hasn't experienced it and
you're leveling up and you're playing
through and you're like hey you should
we could go do this dungeon because you
know it's one more pinnacle to do this
week while you level cool but like at
week 12 when if you've already hit 1560
on pinnacles or whatever there's a lot
less incentive because a lot of the guns
are older
not much like if i go into shattered
throne there's not much in there that
i'm gonna like oh cool i got a
scout rifle from from the dreaming city
there's not much in there i don't think
it's meant for guys like you you know
what i'm saying like yeah you you you're
in that percentile that you're gonna
have most of stuff the only reason
you'll be in there is if you get unlucky
let's be honest right like there's no
reason this is for
i actually like because we used to talk
about this from back in the day like we
all we all agree that raids and dungeons
are some of the best content in destiny
blade even said like but you know this
is one of the reasons why he got into
destiny so there's a huge subset of
people
that just won't run it and you want to
try to give as much incentive impossible
now granted i know it's only one
pinnacle at the end but at least it's
something that it doesn't invalidate the
whole run yeah and you can be of power
you know what i'm saying at the end so
i'm always look i am very biased i am
very pro-rate i'm very pro-dungeon
anything to get more people playing and
trying you know i just ran garden with
uh with the guys and it reminded me i
was like okay still stuff i didn't like
about but i'm like it was decent you
know we got a little conga line together
all right
who's building all right build the thing
back okay cool you know i love that
mechanic if it worked one hundred
percent i know
dj was talking about it it was just like
the problem is like like i think me you
talked about too like somebody should at
least shoot it to activate it there
should be something where someone
shouldn't be able to interfere and then
create another conquer line and mess up
the whole rotation but there were some
things that they did mechanically that
they attempted at least that i thought
was cool and you know divinity all the
mechanics they tried didn't work congo
lines the gambit moat pickups the game
of wolf hiccups it actually kind of
reminds me of the um
the uh the first
uh callus raid where they just had new
stuff like stealth mechanics yeah just
didn't work but it was such a great idea
it just
didn't pan out it just it was just like
i said it's cool to have people
experience it and then like you said e
we have to admit because of the way the
the legendary weapon system is you know
sadly there's still some guns and
archetypes you can only find in these
rays like you said the solar bow and you
know there's certain things you could
only find in these race so hey give me a
second to go in there see what's going
on odysseus said i broke and again
that's one of those hopefully with the
next couple of seasons they fill out
some of these missing archetypes from
sun setting that still like i don't know
how we don't have a solar bow in three
years
if you go for one if you go for void
auto rifles they're legendary two in a
raid and then the other one you gotta
hope either banshee or zurich sell it
because i don't know if you can get a
gnawing hunger from most places anymore
it's a good point those like they're
just weird look because i've been
digging through this like there are
weird ones and again hopefully in
seasons you could probably craft one and
then we'd be totally fine but
right now there are a couple holes but
it is just i'm happy to see them get the
like the rotation of refresh a little
bit of yeah nice work back through there
a little bit of patch notes next week on
tuesday we'll get a patch so no holdings
are hostage
uh wellspring's gonna have a couple fix
uh master if you even complete the
objective close to time you still won't
wipe uh some stuff spawning out of
bounds won't happen altar of reflection
should hopefully be fixed
won't actually like hang out in front of
you and not walk back to his little
platform we've definitely had that
way too many times yeah
we've seen it enough that it's like it's
definitely an issue
trials will have an issue where players
are not receiving expected rewards on
post flawless like if you are flawless
and you're still winning yes you should
be getting drops for sure text chat
virtual keyboard support is now
available on console text chat um more
emphasis on the text chat for consoles
that's a good thing because i even said
tag a message at one point he's like
can't see it i'm like
no i could see it i couldn't respond
yeah that's right i was like but now you
can bring up like your xbox keyboard and
type something back nice
now this is the one where i literally
was recording my like news video for my
channel and i was literally going okay
text chat cool clear text jack color
weapon crafting added a consumable and i
stopped mid-sentence and i went back and
re-recorded because i couldn't i have
this take somewhere but it's like i
re-recorded i'm going
hold on
and i'm going to explain the rest of
this added a consumable
item that allows the viewing of element
counts
this can it can be acquired through the
relic conduit
it is not a limited item you can discard
and reacquire at any time
so
we are losing we're getting rid of some
of the currencies that we have travis is
getting ready
we're losing some of the currency that
we have in season 17.
we have this like the cap for neutral
element went up by like eight percent
and then we have these elements that we
can't see all of them anywhere mostly
and now we're gonna get a new consumable
in our consumables inventory which will
allow you to see
the amount of these elements that you
have
if you've ever seen a band-aid for a
weird situation this is one hundred
percent a band-aid you're not feeling it
travis gets dipped
i'm going to my dim so
i'm weird
so there's two ways to interpret this
message
one is they've created the most insane
system to know how much currency you
have ever
it'd be like checking your credit score
you can do it but you can't do it too
often otherwise it'll it's on a cool
down timer
that would be the craziest thing ever or
we are
they just explained it weird which is
what i think is happening and it's
literally just a box that has the number
or has a number when you put your cursor
over it like that that's a mouse over
type thing like it might be a mouse over
type thing or it literally might just
say the number like all the other
consumables you have or it just tells
you the number and they might have just
described another weird thing is if you
do if you do get a red outline raid
weapon
and it has a raid perk you get what like
12 drowned element
yeah but if you break down a raid weapon
you get a singular drowned element that
actually goes in your consumable
inventory i've had drowned element is in
two different places one i can see one i
could not and i saw that the other day i
was like oh
why do because i saw 12 i was like oh
let me go to consume i still only have
four of these what the
wow that one just like broke my head so
just this one made me laugh i was
i put a tweet out later and i was like
this has to be for one you don't want to
put like six
items into the ui somewhere they're
about to be gone in about six weeks that
would be not worth the effort
neutral element is the one thing that is
basically going to stay around hey right
outside of the ascendant alloy which is
just gonna have a horrible currency cap
and we're not ever going to be able to
acquire it because it's too expensive
anyway but neutral element needs to find
a permanent home somewhere
and maybe this is where this thing lives
but like neutral element if that's like
just the main crafting currency throw it
up there next to my legendary shards i
think i got space they're pretty small
numbers
imagine imagine a world where they
created 40 different consumables so that
you can see
all 40 different currencies that's just
like that's another tab over after
consumables and then system settings and
then
here you go into this trash buyer and
here's all your currencies i have i have
a theory that the reason that they
didn't bake in an easy way for ucla
consumables is because they planned on
making 40 of them and that there was no
feasible way to to represent that in the
ui so they were like all right we just
you know i mean and then they probably
they probably were like oh well now that
we cut down all the different currencies
we're going to add we'll just band-aid
the solution but it's crazy to me man
this
the design on this game i mean i i
understand it's super hard
sometimes they do things i'm just like
guys whoa that's crazy this is the
funniest thing like you know what disre
remember what the dream driver city
first came out
and we used to have to go to petra and
pop a picture
we i'm like i feel like i'm popping a
picture to see
the rest of the consumables
like that's what this feels like i'm
like what is what is what is going on
why do i have to have a consumable i was
like to see stuff like oh i get it it's
cold whatever it's probably a temporary
i just think it's the funniest thing
ever though like we literally gonna pop
a consumable with secrets
yeah
is
i was like this is a weird and that's
why i'm hoping with like neutral element
being the one thing that stays around i
hope this situation is temporary and
trash fire on the inventory those a like
mean thing to say but
it is that's you you read through this
and you're like
just literally a little head-scratching
moment to go
huh this is
this is what we're this is the the and
this is probably the fastest one they
could put in the game
it's just weird anyway i think they just
explained it wrong i think it'll have a
number on the box that you can see
without hovering over it that'd be nice
i was like then why not just put those
elements into your consumable inventory
then ah
i think that's what they did isn't that
what it is it's a consumable to let you
see the number
explained it poorly
yeah it could very well be it could be
who knows i just for the fact that we
got to pop a texture to see the counts i
think it's the funniest thing ever
it's just funny everybody drink your
juices
i don't think you have to use the
consumable to see it i think the
consumable is going to display the
number and you're not actually going to
use the consumable i just i honestly
just think they explained this badly
yeah maybe i think when we see it we
might just go oh yeah that's just like
every other consumable in your inventory
interest
uh the next one is weird players with
all 25 artifact mods unlocked can still
reset the artifact for no additional
glimmer cost
once all
exactly my question when i read this you
got all what you reset and fam the only
reason for all the
somebody said is if their triumph was
bugged or something
oh
but i was like so
but i was sitting there wondering i was
like why would you ever do that and then
finally somebody said that like feels
like you have them all you're good but
the other point is like once all 25
mods are unlocked once all 25 are
unlocked resets are free
at that point i'm like can you just make
them free please stop charging for
resets
yeah oh
man my chat will roast me because i i
used to reset like crazy me too last
season i probably reset like over 50
times oh yeah bro i'm bad i'm bad me no
bro i'm with you i i've liked that
i'll be making i love making bills in
this game so mm-hmm me too
and i'm glad that that they made this
this change this season oh that was for
us
but it was just i was like just make it
free please it's not you don't need it
i agree they definitely should make that
free just like
encourage build diversity people want to
play around man people want to see
you know and and all the limits were
getting annoying you can only have two
in the last slide yeah three years and
just like just like i was saying earlier
i love just testing stuff yeah
and let's be real sometimes you work
that hard to get that stuff blade and
sometimes you test it like damn this is
whack you'll be like oh yeah like i did
all this and this this
if i think if i think something is due
to it doo-doo yeah bro it'd be times i'd
be like yo this ain't as hot as it was
described in the text and then you find
out about you know obviously the
particle deconstructions and the you
know what i'm saying all the fly stuff
that you like damn i should have went
with that you know that kind of thing
yeah so i'm glad we're at that point
give us everything let us you know it's
a season like so many people are never
going to unlock all them don't charge
them if they want to miss up if they
don't play 24 7.
correct final thing of the twab is uh
mex beat monsters by 4 wow
[Laughter]
i was just like oh no i'm sorry i'm
looking like a gun dude oh yeah
i'm not even a titan and i want to see
titans look like that yeah i was like
we're gonna have something to match our
boots lying around
oh that is actually 100 percent true
that actually goes perfectly
mind-blown
yeah didn't even think about that one no
that one i had to go for my brother for
stonewolf um he is
like he grew up like i only know that
gundam exists because of him so
yeah he i definitely had to go team mech
i will say
like the
hunter godzilla cloak
just yeah fire put it in the game like
you could sell both of these and they
would probably sell even more honestly
like you could sell both of these and
honestly i don't know why they don't do
it i can't get on board with the furry
legs on the titan
i would never buy that one for the
cyclops
warlock looks pretty cool the godzilla
cloak or yeah the godzilla cloak looks
cool
but i was like i don't see why
it has to be a vote i know he's like oh
cool like email engagement and stuff
like that but
if you have health engagement
like a mini frieza shoe bro freeze uh
yeah
but honestly like yeah i guess that's
true for the uh for warlock
but i was like you could totally
i don't know i just feel like you can
sell both of them because you literally
i've never seen us that divided i've
never seen it there this was close
monsters
team monster was outside they missed
last time they missed last time and they
missed again and i'm like just let them
have it
i don't think they'll ever win now
because next year this set is going to
be three years old versus the hot
newness yeah
and like how does monster win at this
point it might have won this year but i
think next year and every year after if
they keep putting it in yeah it's never
gonna win one year they're just gonna
have to give it you don't like the fairy
gorilla boots
no i
hate the cycles no i actually really
like the cyclops but as a monster but i
i hate the way it looks on the titan
yeah i don't like that look warlock
creatures in black lagoon godzilla cloak
is fire
titan looks like that all this is cool
you know
harry and henderson's over here so
i don't know how many people are old
enough to even know that movie no no of
course it's a classic classic
so
uh that is mostly what we got for the
epic cyclops from sinbad um
that's mostly what we got
we got raid rotators coming in season
17. season 19 possible reworked gambit
got a new dungeon next season raid in 18
dungeon in 19
lightfall coming
and hopefully before lightfall weapon
crafting is in a better place
yeah man oh yeah and arkansas i'm
definitely excited about uh the whole uh
raid rotation because that's been axed
by a lot
absolutely yeah yeah you're going to be
busy working huh you're going to be busy
you're going gonna be carrying everybody
everywhere be like what do you want to
do i'm gonna play the whole game
oh yeah i mean that's what i do anyway i
mean i just be be vibing and you know
around from with like um mr amaze
himself or i'm oh homie
that's the homie right there salute
[Music]
or if i have like you know my pal right
need to inside the chat or no
rainy
well
yeah i'll just be vibing gaming series
well that is i think about all we got
nice little two-hour show so
save at this point we always like to uh
open the floor to you to kind of tell
you
where people can find you and stuff like
that before you before you say that
stuff i just wanted to thank you for
coming on the show it was our pleasure
to have you somebody with your grand
master and just in game expertise that
you've been at for quite a while um
just very happy to have you on here and
hopefully had a good time on the show
but at this point oh yeah
let everybody know where they can find
you chat with you hit you up on twitter
twitch where are they at
this is your time to give all the
socials
oh yeah you can find me over like um
twitter and
um
twitch over at save the blade would you
know just
yeah getting you two all sorted out uh i
do have like some vids there of some
some solos and stuff but i i am that's
something i've been on the side doing
honestly it's just you know learning my
way inside that space so
um
yeah um
where the channel went was it what's the
twitter where's my school like what's
the what's
we got to send them to the right place
man
don't get shy down with his advertising
if you need a sherpa who can clutch up
all on his own try to try to not die
but just know this man is going to
clutch up yeah and absolutely you say
man and again what you do for the
community and i think your story kind of
resonated with me personally because
you know i i know what it feels like to
oh you know
no galley bus half 15 clears
and um you know you know the lfg vibe
bro right uh lord uh i i literally meme
i literally mean those people i i cuz
like even then like most days i still do
use that elegy at very rarely but when i
do and i see them post i was like oh
just bring this
yup screenshot yeah i i feel you bro
because it's
it's a part of the community that it
really ostracizes a lot of people that
it prevents people from wanting to try
certain some of the destiny's best
content so the fact that you had it
i mean i mean
especially i've been like all alone and
stuff like that like you know i mean i
know what it takes to like you know do
things solo and stuff like that
and you know me doing all this solo
stuff teaches me how to like you know
just like take others through without
without them like requiring much i
because my goal again is to make sure
they're having a good time when i'm
exactly so that's love no brother that's
love i really i love that stuff and it
brings people together and you give
people a positive experience and you
know people get some people get really
emotional because they it's a it's a
game that you it is the friend game and
you really do need people to help you
with you can't solo everything sometimes
so what you're doing salute to you in
the movement salute to the sherpas out
there i'm very appreciative sherpas of
my clan we got back for dead we got dj
we got a forte black iron man in there i
see the whole crew dj is sherpa
dj is the man that's that's listen
that's the bestie right there i'll tell
you right now that that's more like a
shepherd than a sherpa but
yeah a man like that
like that but now salute man i i got i
got a love for you for you and what you
doing what that means to the community
so thanks for coming on you know what
i'm saying so what else is going on trav
with you and e with you what's going to
watch out can you tell us anything
you're doing travis or is it all
yes uh the embargo is technically up on
one of the things i'm working on most of
the stuff is still
in the dark but
i reviewed a game uh the review will be
live on monday morning it's called
postal 4 no regerts
it is a sequel to
a uh a very old game uh
that technically it's a sequel to postal
2
which was hailed as the worst game of
all time
and this is a follow-up to that
and it is worse than that game so
uh i can't talk score yet i'm still
under embargo for final impressions so
i'll give you my early impressions
you should not play this game and i wish
i did not play it uh that's that's my
early impressions really really
impressive there's a little break you
off a preview the remix there uh
yeah so that's how i've been spending a
little bit of my time this last week i'm
sorry we're still around new rad it's
terrible and offensive and and
uh ruined my week and and my girlfriend
isn't talking to me because she has an
option
so um yeah that's that the game this
broker relationship next thing
she's in texas now that's all i can say
she's not here she's in my state i'll go
we'll go ahead and see your statement
wait did you just say you're gonna swoop
on my girl i said we're gonna go have
dinner so my wife
if texas is going to take care of what
san francisco
oh gosh jeez
get him eat
okay i think i think she'll come running
back when she gets taste of that
unseasoned meat
and i mean that i mean that in many ways
there's so much connotation there i'm
going to leave that alone and i need all
of it
um yeah this week also uh you can um you
can find there's no stakes with a1 down
here so you're fine
texas boys pull up
she likes sauce okay
um
steak sauce
earth sauce
that's the one
this segment went left blade is like
what is going on
all right uh
so you can also find me on a little uh
show called defining duke uh i was on um
one of the call and last stand shows
this week to talk about
uh
fair pay and freelance and specifically
a tweet that a lot of people uh got up
in arms about because ign's offered jobs
for 20 news stories uh which is a fair
rate and which i thought was absurd that
people were freaking out about so if you
want to see why i thought it was absurd
uh you can watch that interview and uh
i'm right i guess is the short version
but you should watch it
of course
thank you everyone have a good night
today have a good night don't forget to
tip your waiter uh and uh yeah e what do
you got going on
uh well cog first you got a girl
yeah bro for again shout out to man save
the blade pull it up fun show
oh yeah for me you know finding duke is
in full swing we've been rocking you
know what i'm saying so we had the
thank you brother major episode at uh
dropped off check that out for the
patreons obviously travis pulled up in
rare form great intelligent freelance
discussion loved it and um yeah i'll be
this week this sunday the lord's day we
still be pulling up for me right now
it's all about packs the pax is next
week so
just been booking appointments
travel you know the whole thing and
there's a part of me that misses it
there's a part of me that misses going
to a convention it's a part of me miss i
tell people all the time like as much as
i love the podcast and people say i'm
good at podcasting
i absolutely my favorite thing in the
world is actually talking to developers
right on the release of a game and it's
almost like that indie release album
before anybody knows what's about to
happen
and i got some really cool content and
stuff and all the lords will be there so
if anyone is in the boston area pax east
next week the lords will be there pull
up and uh yeah man we're gonna do a lot
of coverage and also maddie's gonna be
there so the dukes will be there and the
lords will be there so you get to see
all of us at pax east in boston and yeah
that's pretty much it man and uh what
about you e what's going on nice guides
going on what's popping with you in the
channel uh yeah just uh keeping up uh
the nightfall this week is worth doing a
little bit for one easiest nightfall
that we've like had in a while since
it's arms dealer we all know it like the
back of our hand
uh duty bound has some very unique perk
combinations literally can get triple
tap and fourth times the charm and
probably never reload um amongst some
other ones that are just fun so dude how
good is that duty bound back from
it used to be in savathun's song
yes
you got that one uh the chat is off the
rails tonight you guys are killing me
blackwing said something i can't even
repeat right now oh my god i laughed at
it it was amazing
it was great i was like we're late
enough in the show and it was thai guy
sauce and i said that's only for his
girl so
getting get a little after dark here uh
make sure and drink your guys advanced
gigi and next week make sure you guys
tune in we are going to have live mondo
a friend of mine that i've known for a
while into youtube
world he does a lot of solo stuff um and
guides for it and just a small channel
but underappreciated guy has been doing
solo stuff and the reason i say tune in
because dmg tweeted during the show
black wings told me in it
what the twab let's start on the 4 21
next week's swab early oh geez wait what
that's a single section nothing else i
still have more topics to get info on
5600 words for one one topic
fifty six hundred words for one topic on
the twab and he's not done with the twab
it's gonna be huge
yeah oh always do these numbers
when i go to the past pvp i hope so oh
yeah you're gonna be gone next week yeah
we gotta do a show so it's it's gonna
happen
it's gonna be about them finally
figuring out the technical issues and
adding all those 50 currencies that's
why it's 5600 words explaining each
currency
i want to say matchmaking
that would be an interesting discussion
if we get into pvp so weapon swab that's
potentially part of it too so okay
uh but yeah for me streaming elden ring
a lot of that still in kind of a variety
times and then i don't know if i'm gonna
do master raid i think we might try it i
don't know if we're gonna do a ton of no
uh there you go we can call teddy in for
the phil we'll see yeah get a villain um
but yeah just you guys know me destiny
and eldering is pretty much all i'm
playing right now well that's basically
it um shout out to you guys uh remember
use code ebontis or ironlords if you're
picking up some advanced gg stay tuned
got some fun stuff on the horizon there
can't say anything yet just keep your
eyes peeled and other than that same
again thank you for
basically being patient with all of us
being ridiculous today uh but thank you
for also for joining us on the show wow
i i'm very respectful and let you guys
get your stuff out and before i say so
it's always good to hang out here
absolutely
although we're from the weapons sandbox
team to clarify so
oh yeah sandbox patch and and cogs gonna
miss it he misses the sandbox no we're
gonna figure something out
remember
yeah that was the trials relaunch that
was crazy yep um so thank you all very
much for being here episode number 193
uh 200 is
not that far away and i'm working
something for 200 got a couple different
ideas if we can get 200 to be a nice
spicy milestone the week after 200 if
things stay on track is gonna be gcx so
gcx
june 11th and 12th is an off week for
the show for sure uh if we didn't record
anything it would be local for fun and
then we might post it later
but i'm going to be at gcx cod going to
be at gcx travis you know travis is
going to be at g6 i said he's going to
be here
travis is going to be at gcx if you guys
are going to gtx
so if you're going to that one look us
up i'm probably going to be wearing like
an abanta shirt
yeah i'm actually debating on work i'll
talk to you guys afterwards i'm working
on shirt ideas so oh okay
get my next ideas
something yeah
you pulling up what's up man you're
coming to phone you're going to gcx oh
ggcx man what's up
i can't this year oh
sorry sherpa
left off the mountain i had some iro
complications to where i feel
yeah so it's like depending on e3 and
stuff like we almost missed both of
these guys so it's kind of barely come
together
but thank you guys very much um if you
guys are in chat make sure you follow
all of these amazing people thai guy
travis you know go blow up the ign
articles make sure his do well nothing
else
iron lords podcasts
make sure and listen to that one last
and media and save go follow him on
twitter youtube twitch hang out in the
streams blow him up ultra nice guy and
if you need a good sherpa and a nice
sherpa he is your guy yes sir this
episode number 193
april 14th we are wrapping this thing up
so as we always do it has been
the last word
you
did it we did it
all right everybody have a good one
we're out we'll see you soon
you always have to try and steal the
last word cog don't you yeah you hate
wait till after i love that you hate it
so keep doing it
[Laughter]
you know i gotta annoy you sometimes let
me know you stop the uh the recording oh
you guys can stop all right cool
oh right
uh